des professeurs et parents d'élèves
bisontin sur la place granvelle à midi
pour un pique nique dans le cadre du
mouvement national de lutte contre la
réforme de l'éducation nationale voulu
par le ministre jean michel blanquer
moi ce qui me choque le plus c'est la
réforme de la formation des enseignants
puisque bientôt on recrutera des
contractuels pour remplacer les
collègues à l'heure actuelle ça va ça va
dégrader conditions puisque les gens ne
seront pas formés donc on imagine bien
ce que ça peut donner il ya déjà eu des
contractuels de recruter pour pallier au
manque d'enseignants ça a été
catastrophique au niveau du doubs où ils
ont arrêté ça c'est aussi la réforme du
lycée la réforme du bac
et puis après aussi parcours sud qui est
remis en question par rapport à la
sélection à l'entrée à l'université donc
c'est tout ça aujourd'hui qu'on veut
faire passer une liste de transformation
jugée comme une régression du modèle
scolaire français dont l'esprit a
rejoint cet après midi la litanie
entonné ces derniers mois par le
mouvement des gilets jours